[Music]
it's no secret that video games can
launch with some issues but in halo the
Master Chief collection case pretty much
everyone in their dog knew how badly it
stumbled out of the gate I'm Matt and
this is your bug free game spot news
updates
the halo collections issues have largely
been remedied but developer 343
Industries is aware that some problems
still exist community manager Brian
Girard responded to a reddit thread
saying the studio could still end up
fixing these issues in the future I
wouldn't say the ship is totally sailed
yet conversations are still being had
assessments are still being made and at
a minimum I hope to make good on my
pledge to either give fans a legitimate
status update or barring that face it
head-on and even if it's not the news
everyone wants accept it and move
forward Gerard didn't confirm that 343
is working on any fixes but we'll keep
you updated on any developments to this
story for more news from the world of
video games stay tuned to game spot